>> Kimberly: ALL RIGHT.
ED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT UPDATE
AND WE WILL BE WAITING FOR
THAT VOTE TO TAKE PLACE.
JOINING US FOR REACTION ARE
TWO REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
CONGRESSWOMAN MARSHA
BLACKBURN AND MARTHA
BLACKBURN AND MARCHA
BLACKBURN AND MARCH.
TRUMP'S AGENDA IN THIS IS
SOMETHING HE PROMISED AND
NEEDS TO GET A WIN ON THE
BOARD AND PIVOTAL FOR 2018
FOR MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
>> IT IS A BIG WIN,
KIMBERLY, BECAUSE THIS IS
THE TYPE WIN THAT EVERYBODY
IS GOING TO SEE THE RESULTS
AND THE BENEFITS OF.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
AFTER THE FIRST OF THE YEAR,
BECAUSE THESE KICK IN
JANUARY 1, SO, EMPLOYEES CAN
GO SET THEIR WITHHOLDING,
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
MORE MONEY HOME IN THAT
PAYCHECK, BEGINNING IN
JANUARY.
THERE ARE ALSO FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THEIR
TAX SCHEDULES AND SAYING ALL
RIGHT.
WE PAY QUARTERLY.
AND THINK ABOUT MAIN STREET
AMERICA.
ALL THOSE SHOPS THAT LINE
THE STREETS, THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO RE-SET BECAUSE
OF THE LOWER BUSINESS RATES
THAT APPLIES TO ALL OF THESE
SMALL BUSINESSES.
>> Kimberly: COM ROSS STRUM,
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS WORKED
WELL WITH A NUMBER OF CINGTS
THAT HAVE SUPPORTED HIM IN
THE PAST AND ALSO WORKED
CLOSELY WITH PAUL RYAN TO
GET THIS THROUGH.
>> LOOK, IT'S A VERY BIG AND
SIGNIFICANT DAY ALL THE WAIL
AROUND.
THE HEALTHCARE DEBATE.
AND IT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
PEOPLE ON CAPITOL HILL.
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL
RECOGNIZE THAT.
AND SAID LET'S NOT REPEAT
THAT THERE IS AN INTERESTING
DYNAMIC, TOO, IN THAT THERE
IS NO DEFENDER OF THE STATUS
QUO AS IT RELATES TO OUR TAX
CODE TODAY.
THE TAX CODE IS A DISASTER.
70,000 PAGES AND IT'S
HOLDING US BACK.
AND WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO
IN THE COURSE OF THIS
PROCESS IS BRING A WIDE
RANGE OF OPINIONS TOGETHER
NUMBER ONE, OFFERING REAL
TAX RELIEF UP AND DOWN THE
INCOME.
AND, NUMBER TWO, GIVING
BUSINESSES TAX RELIEF AS
MARCIA JUST SAID TO CREATE A
DIFFERENT BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT.
MUCH MORE FORWARD A LEANING.
MUCH MORE INVESTMENT
ORIENTED AND MUCH MORE
EXPANSIVE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK MOST FOLKS ARE REALLY
PLEASED ABOUT.
>> Kimberly: WHERE DO WE GO
FROM HERE COM BLACKBURN IN
TERMS OF THE PRESIDENT
TRYING TO USE THIS FOR MAYBE
OTHER LEGISLATION GOING
FORWARD AS SORT OF A, YOU
KNOW, A FRAMEWORK FOR
SUPPORT TO GET PEOPLE ON
BOARD, TO PUT SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION FORWARD THAT HE
NEEDS.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A
STRUGGLE, YOU KNOW, WITH
TRYING TO REPEAL AND REPLACE
OBAMACARE.
THIS SEEMS TO HAVE GONE MUCH
MORE SMOOTHLY.
>> IT HAS GONE MUCH MORE
SMOOTHLY.
WE FULLY ANTICIPATE THAT YOU
WILL SEE HEALTHCARE COME
BACK IN THE SPRING.
THINK ABOUT THIS LIKE THIS,
KIMBERLY, WE HAVE ADDRESSED
REGULATIONS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN DOING
A GREAT JOB OF WORKING WITH
US.
A LOT OF THAT HAS COME OFF
THE BOOKS.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS
TOGETHER WILL LEAD TO JOB
CREATION.
NOW, THAT MEANS WE NEED TO
PIVOT TO INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WE NEED TO BEGIN TO LOOK AT
SENDING MEDICAID BACK TO THE
STATES.
SO, WE CAN PIVOT.
WORK ON INFRASTRUCTURE.
WORK ON GETTING THE SPENDING
UNDER CONTROL.
2018 IS GOING TO BE A
FANTASTIC YEAR.
IT'S GOING TO BE A YEAR OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
>> Kimberly: ALL RIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN ROSS CAMIN
SUPPORT.
>> THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY
JAMMED THROUGH A MASSIVE
INCOME TAX HIKE IT REALLY
HIT FOLKS IN THE MIDDLE
INCOME AND HIT FOLKS UP AND
DOWN THE SPECTRUM.
THIS IS WELCOMED RELIEF FOR
MY CONSTITUENTS IN SUBURBAN,
CHICAGO AND ALL THROUGHOUT
ILLINOIS.
DIFFERENTLY THAN STATES LIKE
TENNESSEE THAT ARE DOING
BETTER THAT'S OF BETTER TAX
POLICY, ARE GETTING WELCOMED
RELIEF UNDER THIS BILL.
I'M REALLY PROUD TO BE ART
PA OF IT.
>> Kimberly: WE ARE WAITING
AS YOU SEE SENATE VET ON THE